can you teach me how to make an animal
balloon I want to do this definitely
okay okay okay yes I do all right
okay so the important thing is that
first of all when you blow it up you
always want to leave a little room okay
so you got to fill out the room we're
gonna start at the other load up the air
gets pushed nice displacement we're
gonna make just like a standard four
legged animal which is a good base zone
cuz then you can always like elongate
the neck it's a giraffe like everything
it's a poodle yeah so we're gonna start
by making we're gonna twist the balloon
into three circles so you're gonna do
one I'm just afraid it's gonna be wrong
it's totally fine and then you're gonna
do and you know hold on to it okay and
then you're gonna do anything you like
stay like a few times hold now twist
this section oh okay okay okay and now
hold it here not into that that in Terry
are you okay wait so then he so did he
take that okay
[Applause]
so then you got a few more time so you
make a little neck and then you do it
again okay more than another leg we're
gonna edit this try to be gradual one
works going to be great holy I can't say
on day time like that and then what no
no cuz they're gonna lie to you you have
to fix this I don't wanna kill this
Marty okay okay and then you're the last
one
okay yes do it
okay okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this